[Music]
who's ready for a set tour the harry
potter films are filled with magical
sets we all secretly wish we live on but
what was building and acting on these
sets actually like
as much as we all wish hogwarts was real
the truth is only a miniature version of
it was created for exterior shots while
that's impressive in itself there are
still locations you'll recognize in the
uk that they used for the filming of
harry potter durham cathedral anik
castle new college laycock abbey and
gloucester cathedral all hold a tiny bit
of hogwarts with them kind of like a
jigsaw puzzle the philosopher's stone
was the only film that they shot in an
actual location for the forbidden forest
after that it was all up to the set
designers to recapture the magic that
came along with it this was because of
aragog's lair the most challenging part
getting the roots right
the roots became the most interesting
sculptural part of it and the roots got
bigger and bigger
not only did they hand sculpt the trees
and roots but aragog as well by the end
of the films they had created 600 foot
long backdrops of the forbidden forest
and trees that were 12 feet in diameter
watching hogwarts crumble wasn't easy on
anyone especially the set designers the
entire process of creating a destroyed
hogwarts for the big battle took three
months and is where the majority of the
cast said their goodbyes while they
relied heavily on green screen for the
backdrops of the battle all the rubble
rock and explosives we see were added in
when building the set i think sometimes
when something is destroyed it shows the
scale of it they also had the extensive
challenge of making the rubble soft yet
realistic this was because there were
constantly actors running full speed
through the rubble and they didn't want
anyone getting hurt the majority of the
walls and structures were made out of
plywood so they could be realistically
destroyed
diagon alley was probably one of the
more versatile sets the franchise had it
changed for every film depending on what
shops and storefronts were needed for
the storyline however no matter what the
set designers had the challenge of
designing sets that were slanted crooked
and overall very unique
the inspiration for this set was the
stories of charles dickens there was one
scene where they shot on location for
diagon alley in the philosopher's stone
when harry visits the leaky cauldron
that scene was actually filmed at
leidenhall market
believe it or not the diagon alley set
was also used for hogsmeade told you it
was versatile because both towns had the
same wizardry and magical feel they
would switch storefronts add in some
snow and anything else that was needed
and they'd have the small town just
outside of hogwarts that we see harry
and his friends exploring in the
prisoner of azkaban the first time we
see gringotts in the philosopher's stone
the cast actually filmed at the
australia house in london but jumped
forward a decade to the deathly hallows
and the set designers actually
reconstructed the entire set this was
because the flying dragon scene would
have been impossible to film otherwise
if you pay attention you'll see that
while it's almost an exact replica the
designers just couldn't find the same
exact marble floor or wood paneling the
weasley burrow is one of the warmest
sets of the entire film which meant they
had to pay extra attention to all the
family details throughout the films
we've seen many different variations of
the burrow and while they created the
interior of the home for the chamber of
secrets how could we forget the infamous
magical clock and self-washing dishes
they constructed both a new interior and
exterior for the half-blood prince the
ministry of magic set we see in the
order of the phoenix took a whole three
months to build it was important for the
set designers and director to get this
right because it was another extension
of the wizarding world that harry had
never seen before
i've never used the visitors entrance
before
should be fun
the set was so detailed that it included
actual fireplaces where the wizards
traveled using flue powder a daily
profit stand bankers and carts full of
parchment being pushed around by some of
the 300 extras
the room of requirement was probably one
of the most difficult sets to film in
that the crew designed while the novel
describes the room full of cushions and
books they wanted to go a more neutral
route in the film stuart idea was to put
the mirrors all all around the
room and
and very quickly we realized you know
there are no way to avoid reflections
because the room was surrounded with
mirrors they also needed to figure out
the lighting situation which resulted in
many meetings and a discussion to just
go the cgi route in order to get rid of
them as for the cast this set wasn't the
most pleasant either it was just
stifling stifling heat james phelps had
admitted that he hates the room of
requirement set turns out being in a
room full of hogwarts students
practicing magic isn't the most ideal
situation after all in fact bonnie
wright called it suffocating
the great hall is some of the first
magic the characters and the audience
get introduced to the set was built in a
studio but was modeled after the real
life christ church college
along with the hall set designers also
crafted dumbledore's lectern and the
hogwarts house point counter an item
that was said to have been the cause for
a national shortage of indian glass
beads if you need any more proof the
great hall is its own kind of magic the
reaction we see of the first years
walking in during philosopher's stone is
their raw reaction that was the first
time they had stepped onto that set
whenever we have a new cast member
coming they always talk about when they
walked into the great hall set because
it's just it's amazing the great hall
was used for the six following films and
was even transformed for the ewo ball in
the goblet of fire a set actor warwick
davis loved mostly because he got the ok
to crowdsurf during filming
we see dumbledore's office a few times
throughout the films which means they
constructed it completely in the studio
to use in each film they made sure that
they stuck very close to the books for
this set even including the 48 portraits
of the headmasters bookshelves that had
books mentioned in the novels the sword
of gryffindor his memory cabinet and
finally the pen sieve this even doubles
as the room where lupin and harry
studied magic together in the prisoner
of azkaban they just switched out the
props this hogwarts washroom set from
the half-blood prince may not have been
memorable to us but for tom felton it's
one of his favorite scenes he's ever
shot this was because of how practical
they made the set for the effects we see
on screen
when we did spells normally not a lot
actually happened but in this case they
rigged the whole bathroom up with
explosives so every time you gave a
little flick something would blow up
which was very satisfying when harry
makes his way into the chamber of
secrets in the second film what we see
there was entirely constructed in studio
however in the last film they recreated
that set using vfx and green screen
excuse me sir can you tell me where i
might find platform nine and three
quarters i think you're being funny do
you harry potter wouldn't be harry
potter without platform nine and three
quarters there's just something about
running through a brick wall that gets
you every time while the majority of
these shots were done in the real world
at king's cross station in london for
the final film they recreated the
platform the train and the tracks for
interior shots
they transformed an old steam engine
into the hogwarts express and would film
it moving along tracks for exterior
shots we all know how huge the harry
potter franchise is around the globe but
it is still shocking that they were able
to get permission to close down london's
piccadilly circus for this deathly
hallows scene that's basically the times
square of london in deathly hallows part
1 shortly after the golden trio leave
fleur and bill's wedding they find
themselves in piccadilly square
surrounded by hundreds if not thousands
of others in order to get this scene
shot they had to block off certain parts
of the road and gathered crowds of
extras to cooperate with their filming
but still ran into other challenges we
were surrounded by paparazzi which is
also not great because of the flashing
of their cameras
while cgi and vfx are a big part of
these films there's nothing like
practical set building to get that epic
final result on screen even if the
actors were a little suffocated
sometimes what was your favorite set to
take a look behind the scenes at